we've just stayed one day away from the
raiders season opener at a legion
stadium and to get inside you must have
your covid 19 vaccine 8 news now has you
covered before the big game let's send
it out to kate houston who is live
outside of allegion stadium where fans
are getting cleared for tomorrow hey
there kate
yes well this is offered to fans who are
unable to verify their vaccine status
through that clear health app now behind
me this is where that screening was
today it ended about 30 minutes ago but
it will be back tomorrow at this white
tent this is in lot b now community
ambulance says more than a thousand
people were here yesterday and they
expected another thousand today
[Applause]
excitement is brewing for las vegas
raiders fans i've been a raider fan
since i was nine years old i've been a
many many raider games home and away
covid 19 vaccines are required in order
to get into the game we're 110 behind it
so we're happy we're excited to be here
we can't wait for tomorrow the alternate
screening area is for those who are
partially vaccinated those whose vaccine
is not supported by the app those who
are unable to upload their vaccine card
or for those bringing a 12 to 13 year
old that is unable to be added to the
app great it's fast it's wonderful they
did a great job
that's what happens when you be early 30
seconds it was done id proof in and out
glenn simpson with community ambulance
says the more people that are cleared
ahead of time the shorter the lines will
be tomorrow anything we can do to get
them in the gates quickly and more
efficiently is what we want to do
raiders fans from across the nation
utilize the alternate screening area
saying they'll do what they need to in
order to watch their favorite team in
person tomorrow that's why they call it
raider nation because we're one big
family
[Applause]
well back out here live alternate
screening will start here in this white
tent in lot b tomorrow at 1 pm and at
that time fans can also get their first
or second dose of the covid 19 vaccine
they will be considered partially
vaccinated and they will have to wear a
mask during the game reporting live
outside of allegion stadium kate houston
8 news now